mercier le derrière alors valérie donc
on voit bien dans cet extrait que vous
l'avez vous avez initié dieudonné
pendant le tournage je promets une chose
votée au bo jolis vêtements je dis pas
qu'il est mal habillés mais c'est vrai
que à des costumes plus classique des
masques de beauté beauté maquiller au
banco à la proximologie vie si oui la
poudre chocolatée il leur métier fait
tout le tournage avec de la poudre
chocolatée métier noir pendant le film
c'est ça c'est l'historien salade
musique là bronzé aussi quand même mais
c'est un bronzage nature et moi ça me
direz-vous l'amérique et s'éteint c'est
guy larrieu hommes
oui j'ai un c'est guy larrieu la maison
à la maison dites moi votre première
télé c'était l'académie des neuf de jean
pierre foucault riz un don vous y êtes
allé avec une amie qui travaillait sur
le plateau il n'y avait pas de pas de
candidat vous appris comme candidat je
voulais pas aller à la télé et on m'a
dit à personne est ce que tu veux y
aller on biomimétique est mari parce
qu'elle est pas d'étiquette la mise à
jour commencé mais par des malentendus
on n'en sait toujours trompés agents se
tromper de nombreux noms seront mais
vous avez gagné une caméra quand même
oui mieux qu'une caméra une machine à
coudre des tas de choses
un sac à pain un sac à pain un coffret
de 10 me maria callas un coffret dit ce
matin par madame héritiers qui voient là
madame reiki madame ont épié
dites moi alors vous avez quand même un
jugement très négatif s'est pas mariée
maman si vous ignorez - le feuilleton
oui bah oui attendait pas revu depuis
l'émission de samedi 15 veronica vous
entendez par vu marie laforêt n'y a rien
entre eux pour le moment
bon alors non vous avez un jugement
comme négatifs sur la télé vous dit par
exemple que souvent on dit que c'était a
fait hier soir tu as fait quelque chose
hier soir non j'ai regardé la télé oui
on me demandait la différence entre le
cinéma et la télévision je disais quand
on dit qu'est ce que tu as fait ce après
midi je suis allé au cinéma
qu'est ce que tu as fait ce après midi
rien j'ai regardé rien j'ai regardé la
télé voilà c'est vrai je vois les gens
disent ça sauf quand il parle de tout le
monde en parle mais sinon oui il ya
beaucoup d'émissions et vous ne
connaissez pas faire quelque chose c'est
attendre dit à la télé on vous pose
jamais les bonnes questions balizy poser
les bonnes questions
bah oui c'est pour ça que je vous dis ça
plus et plus il ya dix ans c'est
possible vous dites par exemple quand
j'ai trop parlé à la télé alors j'espère
vous allez parler soir parce que si l'on
souhaite terrible dit quand j'ai trop
parlé à la télé je voudrais faire un
petit trou dans la terre et disparaître
dedans et c'est vrai parfois quand je
parle trop c
c'est vrai qu'en ce moment je suis tout
le temps en interview j'ai envie de me
taire oui bon ça assez salutaire
bon mais ses terres taisez-vous 10
secondes mais vous dites quand on
s'était salah ben oui hein vous est
propre
l'attrition la prison vous dis-je moi
j'aimerais bien faire une télé avec des
invités qui viendrait pas uniquement
pour vendre quelque chose ou est ce que
les invités viennent quand ils ont un à
vendre cet été laissant aimerait faire
une émission de parts par dieudonné qui
lui l'état et la politique d'abord être
est désintéressé puis ensuite à toute
politique en politique comme home
humanis hommes humaniste il te pisse
utopiste voilà aussi un petit peu
éclairé le public le peuple français qui
les regardent qui l'on regarde qui
regardent votre mission il rit et qui
est certainement intéressés par ce que
je veux dire tout à l'heure chapeau bas
bon alors mais là j'espère vous n'êtes
pas là pour vendre si vous avez par les
biens sont restés presque à la fin oui
oui moi je tiens à vous non je suis
présenté notre avis parce que voilà dans
le film didier braun gardons dans le
film ça vous fait un personnage
formidable et alors il est à peu près le
contraire du de son rôle parce qu'il est
à l'accent du nord il vient du nord il
est pas danseur donc il a pris des cours
de danse il aa pris l'accent du sud est
devenu danseur à l'accent du sud alors
qu'il est comédien à l'accent du nord
c'est pour ça que je suis venu là ce
soir pour bien dire j'étais pas
montpellier
vous n'êtes pas de montpellier non non
c'est bien la leçon ah oui faites-le
pour voir la voulez que je fasse comme
sa puce sais mais ça pendant tout le
film génial
voilà ce film ce film
s'appelle le derrière donc à un mois
c'est assez joli je trouve assez déçu et
assez enfantin c'est un mot qu'on
emploie plus beaucoup non non non mais
ça veut dire beaucoup de choses et le
derrière premier et deuxième degrés tout
ce qu'on veut c'est les gars vous avez
loupé de factures c'est justement c est
moi je préfère faire écrit cuit pour
autant peut-on suisse a failli s'appeler
maman j'ai sucé papa assane ndiaye
j'avais dit un jour un studio magazine
véronika loubry qui disent ah oui
abandonnant sa jamais été écrit sur le
nom ç'a failli s'appeler fruiterie c'est
vrai qu'il était sur le tournage pour
pouvoir louer des dvd odile et mettre
nos camions on a on a mis un titre ne
pourra pas avoir toujours à s'expliquer
par claude rich et croyez vraiment que
ça allait s'appeler frifri quand ils le
veulent puissent dans les rues quand sa
fille a dit papa tu joues dans un film
qui s'appelle le derrière ils étaient
moins content quand même
oui mais quand il a vu le fus mines
étaient très contents d'être absolument
bon là c'est nous qu'on a souvent viré
télévision qui parce qu'on a vu chez
drucker par exemple dimanche dernier où
elle va pisser où le nom de la commune
vous avez appris à marcher comme ça
comment ça s'est passé hier que ces
[ __ ] dans la démarche passe à celle
que moi si on me demandait vraiment de
faire pipi comme un garçon je sais le
faire
oui je le faisais dans mon premier
spectacle mais là je me suis dit voilà
une fiche ne sais pas d'ailleurs elle a
jamais quasiment vu d'hommes de sa vie
la seule chose qu'elle connaisse de la
sexualité c'est des saillies des chevaux
et donc je sais je me suis mise à la
place d'une fille qui ait jamais vue
d'homme de sa vie et qui pensent faire
pipi comme un garçon alors j'imagine
très mal moi même un garçon en train de
marquer les jambes comme ça pique ça
n'existe pas à part au camp siffredi qui
peut pas faire autrement oui mais les
autres mais lui serait très loin mais
c'est vrai depuis les visiteurs vous
avez pris un peu conscience on peut dire
de votre corps vous assumez mieux non
pratiquement ben c'est à dire que quand
j'ai commencé à jouer j'étais très jeune
et genre et je faisais sûrement pas
jeunes et voilà je me remets un peu je
retourne dans mon âge alors dans le film
qu'on vous voit de dos on voit on voit
vos fesses à votre derrière donc est
devant vous aviez quoi alors
et bien je m'étais coller un petit
post-it parme pour me préserver de mire
fait ces postures et comment il est plus
festive jaune armes
est ce qu'il est et grands mais parce
que toi des fossiles tu les vois ce jour
les potiers sont noirs tous les sites
sont dépassés ah ouais non alors il
n'était pas cachée c'était un groupe
hostile ou égaré comme ça mais bon
j'avais mis en triant c'est vrai que
gildas la première fois que il vous à
interview à la télé vous avez dit que
vous avez un physique difficile
oui mais j'avais je trouve qu est ce que
vous voulez dire il s'y connaît
quand on vous dit des choses comme ça
vous avez pas dire non ouais bon alors
dernière question enfin dernière sur le
sujet vous dit vous dites dans vous
dites toujours dans la promo frédéric
elle est comme ça parce que finalement
elle mélange un peu tout les tous les
homos ils croient que les homos sans
pareil
elle confond les faux lasser les top
classe vous dites que c'est sa vision
des homos qu'elle se fait une fausse
idée d où vient ce service sur la place
des femmes auprès des eaux moore est ce
que tout ça c'est pas des alibis parce
qu'il n'est pas politiquement correct de
dire que vous avez fait un film qui
caricaturent les homos mais je pense que
ça qu'un cas parce que ça caquette sûr
pas du tout je pense qu on envoie pour
une fois de toutes sortes c'est à dire
qu'il ya plein de gens qui s'imaginent
que sous les ordres sont comme ça et je
pense que il ya des ministres et a
débouché il ya des des maquilleurs iliad
et donc moi je pense que c'est pas une
caricature puisqu'il y en a il y en a
dix ans oui mais enfin j'ai l'impression
en vous entendant en lisant vos
interviews que vous n'arrivez pas à dire
ce que vous êtes peut-être vous avez
peur ce pas très politiquement correct
de dire oui j'ai fait un film pour me
[ __ ] de la gueule des homos après tous
mes amis alors